Hollywood is an ever-changing landscape
and nobody knows that better than action
stars of years gone by from world karate
champions to kung-fu prodigies these
actors were born to be action heroes but
for one reason or another they all wore
out their welcome in the movie business
Michael Dudikoff spent years feeding off
fit parts before he won the role of
private Jyoti Armstrong in 1985 s
American ninja which marked the
beginning of his time as the Golden Boy
of Canon films in the years that
followed canons owners managed to keep
him at the B film studio by promising
him all kinds of meaty roles due to
cuffed old coming soon there were so
many things I was told I was going to be
I was going to be Superman I was going
to be spider-man that never did happen
but they were working on it instead of
playing superheroes he fronted such SLOC
classics as avenging force and platoon
leader in the years following American
ninja Canon bought the rights to
Superman at a steel but they managed to
convince Christopher Reeve to reprise
the role in the critically panned
Superman for the quest for peace Duda
cough went on to make more American
ninja movies which he remains best known
for today in his own words I'd like to
work a little more but I'm here when
Danish model Brigitte Nielsen was
offered the chance to transition into
movies she had a tough decision to make
her first marriage was over and she had
a young child to look after but the part
was too big to decline she told The
Guardian I let my parents bring up my
son Julian to pursue my Hollywood dream
I got the opportunity to appear in a
movie called Red Sonja with Arnold
Schwarzenegger soon after portraying the
sword wielding Marvel heroine Nielsen
appeared in rocky 4 with Schwarzenegger
rival Sylvester Stallone sly became her
second husband and they starred
alongside each other in 1986 his Cobra
before calling it quits the statuesque
blonde went on to appear in 1987's
Beverly Hills Cop 2 and fronted a number
of largely forgettable action movies
throughout the 90s but the a-list status
she coveted in those early days slowly
slipped away today Nielsen is best known
for her stints on various reality TV
shows and recently made headlines in
June 2018 when she gave birth to her
fifth child at the age of 54 and I am
the happiest mother I probably the
happiest I've ever been
she might not be getting the biggest
rolls anymore but she remains a super
woman in real life blade certainly
wasn't perfect about Wesley Snipes anew
and physical prowess turned the Marvel
vampire movie into a cult classic that
would spawn two sequels one that was
relatively enjoyable and one that was
downright awful Snipes behavior on the
set of blade Trinity is now a thing of
legend speaking to AV Club patton oswalt
revealed how the leading man fell out
with director David s Goyer Big Time the
fact that movie exists puts it above
Citizen Kane according to Oswalt things
got so bad that Snipes would apparently
only communicate with the director
through post-it notes signing off each
one with from blade onset feuds turned
out to be the least of Snipes worries he
wound up serving two years behind bars
after he was found guilty of tax evasion
bringing his time as an a-list action
star to an end
he had a stint as a linebacker for the
Oakland Raiders in the early 70s but
Carl Weathers retired from football
after catching the acting bug he paid
his dues and small roles for film and
television
until rocky came along his character
flamboyant boxer Apollo Creed continued
to pop up in the franchise until his
death in the ring in 1985 s rocky for
the death of Apollo Creed didn't mark
the end for weathers however he went on
to appear alongside Arnold
Schwarzenegger in 1987 s predator he led
his very own action outing the following
year with action Jackson but the movie
was torn to shreds by critics
weathers defended the film in a 2009
interview with bullseye saying I still
maintain today that it could have been a
better movie had we taken a little bit
longer to develop the screenplay
a lot of people liked it in Germany it
was huge success in Europe wasn't enough
to convince the studio to make a sequel
however and a planned action Jackson
franchise was canned
whether still makes a living as a
character actor today his name is Carl
Weathers and he's my new acting teacher
but his time as an action hero is well
and truly over gently was just 11 years
old when a producer stumbled across him
giving a kung fu demonstration in Hong
Kong impressed with Lee's skills the
producer came back to visit him every
year to check his progress he was 17
when the exec decided he was old enough
to start making movies and before long
he was a star in his native China Lee's
first american movie was 1998 Lethal
Weapon 4 he played a villain but he
didn't have to wait long for his first
hero role in 2000 Romeo Must Die was a
modest hit for Lee the tragic death of
Lee's Coast
Ilia put the idea of a proposed sequel
to bed Lee remained a hot property in
Hollywood for a while and was even
offered a role in The Matrix franchise
but the actor and his family were almost
killed in the Boxing Day tsunami of 2004
seeing the destruction firsthand made
him want to dedicate more time to
philanthropy rather than filmmaking
after struggling through school with
undiagnosed dyslexia Billy Blanks turned
away from the books and started to focus
on martial arts if he couldn't succeed
academically he wanted to excel at
karate instead he told CNN sooner or
later I started to see myself progress
the next thing you know I got my black
belt before everybody in the class he
went on to become a seven-time world
karate champion and attained black belts
and several other martial arts before he
decided he needed new challenge
Hollywood blanks had the fighting skills
to make it as an action star but his
trouble with reading proved problematic
luckily his wife helped him memorize
scripts and soon enough blanks was
rubbing shoulders with some of actions
biggest stars appearing in Jet Li's the
master jean-claude Van Damme's
a wall and the Bruce Willis led action
comedy The Last Boy Scout in 1992 he was
finally rewarded with his first lead
part though talons of the Eagle wasn't
exactly star maker material Hollywood
forgot about blanks over the years that
followed and today he's best known as
the inventor of Tae Bo a total body
fitness system that he apparently came
up with while listening to the rocky
soundtrack he could have been a
household name today but Kenpo expert
Jeff Speakman failed to capitalize on
his strong and entertaining debut in
1991's the perfect weapon speakman had a
three-picture deal with paramount but
changes were afoot within the studio and
the project that was being developed as
a follow-up vehicle was accidentally
sold to Fox who refused to sell it back
speakman told the action elite they made
that movie which was supposed to be my
second movie at Paramount and the name
of that movie was speed it was the movie
that made Keanu Reeves a star he lost it
and consequently there went my career
the movie that speakman wound up doing
instead two years later was Street
Knight two years might not seem like a
significant absence but countless
similar movies came out in that time
Street Knight got lost in the noise and
soda
speak man who stopped acting in 2006 he
was diagnosed with throat cancer in 2013
but he did what he does best and fought
it by 2014 he'd been given the all-clear